[Music]
Kylie Jenner is officially a mom I can't
wait to be a mom even though I'm 15 I
would love 20 year old Kylie has a lot
to celebrate in 2018 the youngest
kardashian-jenner welcomes her first
child with rapper Bo Travis Scott
while the reality star stayed low-key
throughout her pregnancy covering up her
baby bump when out and about and posting
pics concealing her growing belly
there were several clues about Kylie's
upcoming bundle of joy she and sister
Khloe Kardashian made a possible
reference on the pair's dual pregnancy
status in a YouTube collab for Kylie
cosmetics together we ate a source told
et in September Kylie was expecting a
daughter Chloe even seemed to hint at
the gender of Kylie's child baby girls
in honor of Kylie I'm calling my baby
girl when your kids your babies have
babies it's magic it really is
momager Kris Jenner also gave fans a
clue about her family expanding on a
holiday episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians I used to pray that one of
you guys would have a baby and now it's
like a faucet that we turned on again
so the fact that I have all the
grandchildren
it's
to watch your kids because it's truly
believing of just left
congrats to Kyle Isel on her new edition
[Music]
you